[Musique]
je m'appelle Adrien privé je travaille
donc à airbusif en face ici en salle
blanche je suis ingénieur de production
ingénieur méthode production ici on
fabrique des cartes électroniques qui
sont intégrés ensuite dans les
satellites pour airbusifs and space mon
travail consiste à mettre en place des
nouveaux produits
l'industrialisation de ces nouveaux
produits notamment et également faire du
suivi de prod global pour nos projets
récurrents on produit plus des
satellites qui coûtent des millions
d'euros et en industrialisation et même
en bureau d'études le nexpace s'est
trouvé une nouvelle philosophie de
production c'est produire avec déjà des
composants grand public donc on est plus
sur des composants spécifiques aux
spatial et c'est produire avec des
nouvelles règles d'industrialisation qui
sont beaucoup plus optimisées depuis une
cinquantaine d'années on a l'habitude
d'envoyer des satellites deux par deux
donc des très gros satellites qui
coûtent extrêmement cher maintenant la
nouvelle mode on va dire c'est c'est les
constellations c'est envoyé en fait des
grades de satellites donc on peut en
être 30 40 par fusée c'est des tout
petits satellites pour un ordre de
grandeur un satellite
classique un satellite on va dire
standard c'est de la taille d'une
camionnette un satellite constellation
on va plus se retrouver aux alentours
d'une taille d'une machine à laver notre
carte électronique elle arrive chez nous
complètement vierge donc faut aussi
imaginer comme une feuille qui contient
une vingtaine de couches à peu près on
peut aussi les entre 10 et 30 couches
combat positionner donc ici sur le
convoyeur d'entrée
cette cette carte elle va passer ensuite
dans cette machine qui va nous permettre
de déposer la crème à braser sur la sur
le PCB donc la crème à braser
globalement c'est des petites des
petites doses d'alliage qui vont
permettre ensuite de pouvoir solidariser
les composants sur sur le PCV sur la
carte électronique ici vous êtes sur la
machine de contrôle cette machine elle
va contrôler ce qu'on a fait auparavant
en sérigraphie on va vérifier
globalement que la dépose est conforme à
nos attentes et à nos critères donc
cette machine globalement c'est une
machine qui va prendre des photos en 2D
en 3D de la carte et qui va analyser les
dépôts sur toute la carte on passe un
peu sur la plus grosse machine de la
ligne celle qui va vraiment poser les
composants sur la carte électronique
donc vous avez la chance de pouvoir
l'avoir en action actuellement
et en plus vous avez la chance d'avoir
une carte next face sous les yeux donc
cette carte c'est une carte du projet
one sat par exemple
vous voyez qu'on a quand même une
cadence assez importante là on a une
cadence d'à peu près 7600 composants à
l'heure cette carte là qui possède à peu
près 3000 composants un quart d'heure
elle est
elle est finie on peut observer là du
coup la sérigraphie qu'on a fait sur la
première machine et aussi les composants
qui ont été déposés par la machine
précédemment il faut veiller à ne pas
toucher cette carte actuellement parce
que les composants ils sont juste posé
en fait faut dire que la crème abraser
actuellement
c'est comme une sorte de dentifrice donc
les composants ils sont juste posés sur
du dentifrice il faut bien vous dire que
là on retourne la carte tous les
composants tombent pour justement
solidariser tous les composants qu'on
aura posé sur la carte électronique
sur cette carte on va utiliser cette
machine donc cette machine c'est ce qui
s'appelle un four eBay un four à
refusion le principe de fonctionnement
il est assez simple on a un fluide à
l'arrière de la machine qui est en
ébullition constante et ces vapeurs
montent à peu près 240 degrés notre
carte elle va rentrer dans ce four elle
va aller au fond au fond du four donc
c'est le fond de la cuve qu'on voit
derrière et la carte elle va faire des
des va-et-vient enfin des hauts et des
bas plutôt pour
braser correctement les composants sur
sur toute sa face là il faut vous dire
que la carte elle est quasi terminée
elle est même terminée parce que cette
machine va pas apporter de réelles
valeurs ajoutées à la carte elle va
contrôler tout ce qu'on a déposé sur la
carte ce qui est essentiel et même
indispensable en vue des critères
qualités que l'on se doit de respecter
[Musique]
à la fin de la ligne auto les éventuels
non conformité qu'on aurait pu observer
sont corriger immédiatement après par un
opérateur manuel une fois que notre
équipement il est contrôlé vérifié testé
on peut l'envoyer vers nos clients que
ce soit en termes Toulouse ou on a
également des clients externes satellite
on les garantit entre 15 et 17 ans dans
l'espace et contrairement à votre
voiture par exemple si vous avez une
panne il est impossible de le réparer
entre le moment où la carte est lancée
le moment où elle va elle va être
intégrer dans le satellite il se passe
environ 9 mois 9 à 12 mois et ensuite
par contre on va attendre un ou deux ans
jusqu'au lancement réel du satellite
intégré dans la fusée